herzlich kommst du denn folge ich fahre
leute und herz bekommen zu einer ganz
besonderen folge leute wir sind heute in
der stadt in der ich viele jahre meines
lebens verbracht habe mein abitur
gemacht haben unsere schule gegangen bin
aschaffenburg wir fahren heute diesen
wunderschönen golf 6 + 1 2 tsi gesehen
heute das ist ja normal
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nach den ganzen schnitten leute die wir
hatten ja einen turbo s 710 ps wir
hatten in einer einzigen zwei carrera 4
gts wir hatten tesla model 3 letzte
woche unsere e klasse dachte ich mir
jetzt ist auch mal schön wenn ich euch
nochmal persönlichen einblick in das
auto von meiner mama fahre
denn ja da hat ja auch viel angefangen
das ist ein auto mit vier vorgeschichte
hat damals meiner stimme gehört papi und
ja ich würde sagen wir laufen andere mal
dann erste frage man weiß ja nicht genau
wo ich meine begeisterung für autos her
haben ja aber vielfach nicht von dir
nein nicht verlieren wie viel ps hat ein
auto 85 tagen sind 85 ps nein nein 105
so viele 105 vierzylinder benziner auf
175 newtonmeter und so viel ich habe
mich auch auf dem fahrrad oder das was
haben wir drauf 205/55 r 16 16 zoll
felgen marschall anbrachte hier die
heckklappe die da ist die omi mit ihren
85 jahren weil mit offener heckklappe in
die garage rauscht oder stimmt hier ja
das hatte das hat der historischen wert
hier unsere wie gesagt unsere omi die
jetzt nicht mehr unter uns weilt
von der ist nach dieser schaden hier und
ja wir sind ja golf plus ja also ich bin
eigentlich sehr zufrieden mit dem auto
geschenkten gaul schaut man nicht ins
maul das auto habe ich ja von meiner
stift mama geerbt
anfänglich war ich etwas irritiert weil
es eine automatik getriebe hat und ich
sehr gerne schaltung fahrer und da kann
man diese starken 105 ps gar nicht so
richtig ausfahren wenn man keine
schaltung und dann finde ich es ein
bisschen komisch dass das man da so rein
steigt das ist ja ein auto für ältere
leute da ist der boden etwas angehoben
ja komplett also kombinieren wir immer
vorne auf macht das ding ist halt schon
relativ hoch dass es wie so ein
fahrendes kastenbrot ich meine
einsteigen
also man kann auch super aus aufstehen
das ja fast stabhochsprung erste tor zu
kommen leute diejenigen vielleicht viel
auto fahren wissen es gibt so gewisse
autos bei dem man bei der hat man schon
sorgen wenn die vor allem auf der
autobahn sind c 180 kompressor einige
andere aber auch golf plus also was ich
sagen will leute dieses dieses klischee
dass golf sechs fahrer nicht die
begabtesten autofahrer überhaupt sind
das stimmt auf jeden fall und damit
jetzt hat ja dann
[Musik]
werthmann schwester absetzen leute ich
immer kurz die aufnahme was haben wir
hier für ein multimedia-system mama was
ist das das ist ja das ist einmal die
schlumpfhausen edition da ist nirgendwo
ein aux anschluss jetzt das auto hat
keinen autobahnanschluss waren bogen ja
was haben wir sonst
wir haben hier eben verrät hier leute
dsg also automatikgetriebe und ja halt
sonst golf 6 wie sicherlich auf einige
von euch hin kennen was ist das
eigentlich
also das ist man das ist mein der magnet
für meine navigation bitte was der
magnet für deine navigation in diesem
format ist immer was bedeutet es für
dich also im auto brauche ich nur sehr
selten weil ich meistens fahrrad war
stimmt das ist echt krass also und mama
fährt wirklich so also ich weiß nicht
woran das fest macht das jetzt den tag
gekommen
es wurde auto fährt zwar wirklich es
können minus 31 grad sein meterhoch pack
als auf der straße ist heute mit wieviel
fährst du pro jahr wie viel kilometer
dem pfarrer hat dem auto ganz wenig
wahrscheinlich liegen wahrscheinlich mit
dem fahrrad zum ausdruck wir also wir
können das nicht genau ermitteln heute
aber ich würd mal sagen einstelliger
tausender bereich also unter 10.000
kilometer früher hier kann es mal
geradeaus
ist das krass ist dass klassiker ich
steige wirklich ein und ich sitze wie im
bus als würde ich jetzt 30 grundschüler
in die schule fahren kann wie hoch man
muss ja erstmal hier muss ja erstmal
runterkommen
das war aber nicht abgemacht dass du mir
mein ganzes auto verstellt
das gemacht hat ich kann mir kaum ein
kopf bewegt kann ich das wieder
hinkriegen
ich werde das wieder alles gut so also
wir merken direkt ich habe schon mal zu
mama gesagt golf 6 plus fahren hier denn
hier ist wie busfahren für mich du hast
wirklich ein gigantisches lenkrad das
ist gigantisch eine ahnung dass
erstreckt sich fast bis zum beifahrer
das lenkrad bringen so konnte sitzt so
hoch und das ist sowieso ein bisschen so
eine schaukel schiff wenn man das mal zu
einer sportlichen fahrzeuge vergleich
aber ich hätte das auch nicht ich kann
dieses auto auch nicht helfen ich mache
auf eine liebevolle art und weise
manchmal eine spesen hier weil am ende
ist es immer noch das auto von unserer
uni und deswegen gibt es da nichts zu
retten aber es fährt sich nicht schlecht
muss ich sagen also ja es fährt sich
nicht schlecht also das lenkrad ist so
sehr komisch aus aber das geht ja kann
ich ja eine ganze menge bewegen bisher
das auto erst mal reagiert also ist es
schlecht bis halt nicht dafür ist ja
kein sportliches fahrzeug ist ja klar
das macht das was machen soll und golf 6
sowieso nicht richtig in den fingern
leute dieses auto jetzt direkt zu
launchen jetzt denken wir immer eine
kurve hat aber auch vorteile
das nicht mehr sagen welche vorteile ja
also klar ich dachte ich das ist
schlecht das auto ist sowieso nicht gut
man kann nicht sagen dass der golf ein
schlechtes gewissen gab stabiles auto
also was ich gut finde an dem auto ist
man es ist so super quadratischen das
kann man ganz toll einparken er ist
quadratisch ist so weiß genau was ändert
das ist einfach toll ja und ich habe
auch apps nur das was machst du ps was
eps irgendwas was hilft in der not wenn
es irgend eine krisensituation gibt im
fahrzeug okay aber nicht wie man sich
die sp oder doch doch das meine ich okay
okay leute dann würde ich mal sagen wir
sind pumpen mond jaletzke
das hat echt ja ja gut ja das ist ein
praktisches auto das ist jetzt nicht für
so nicht so holzköpfe wie mich gemacht
dass es nicht gemacht wenn wir zu
ballern und irgendwie den dicken zu
machen weil man denkt man bekommt damit
mehr mädels was eigentlich meistens
nicht der fall ist sondern ist einfach
ein praktisches auto ist erfüllt genau
sein zweck und für das was es machen
soll
find ich es wirklich gut muss ich sagen
was auch super ist du kannst die
rückbank umlegen und hast eine super
ladefläche du kriegst du recht
ordentlich rein und ich krieg da mein
vater zwei große 28er fahrräder kriege
ich in das auto rein raus erst mal
nachmachen da geht echt mega vieler 100
sich einmal klick dauern
aber das auto fährt sich sehr
komfortabel auf jeden fall entspannt das
geil und interessant ist auch was ist an
versicherung kostet im jahr stimmt ja
und du hast auch eine krasse schalter
kostet 252 euro versicherungen im ganzen
jahr
also bitte an der kurve deine these
zehnmal so viele leute alle die selbst
schon mal ein auto sich versicherte
müssen dass es geisteskrank wenig aber
ja wenn man jetzt hier so bei innenstadt
tempo ein bisschen schneller möchte
macht er auch kein problem also wird es
jetzt gefragt welches auto würde für
deine eine situation passen hätte ich
wahrscheinlich auch so was gesagt wie es
gut ist ein auto der vernunft ganz
einfach ja auf jeden fall finden auch
schlauer also man muss am ende auch
sagen leute dieses auto thema kann auch
echt krass viel geld verschlingen
deswegen wenn man für sich sagt ich hab
gar nicht so eine passion dabei beste
idee einfach und drei jahre alten wagen
zu kaufen paar jahre zu fahren abzugeben
so allerdings habe auch ich in meinem
schon etwas längeren leben auch mal eine
phase gehabt wo mir das irgendwie
wichtig war was ich gefahren bin ja
stimmen erzielt hatte ist ein bmw cabrio
oder so genau
ich hatte einen 325 ihn golf cabriolet
60 länder wieso hellgrauen ledersitzen
da blieb kein auge trocken sind auto hat
mir mein bruder konfiguriert der hatte
einen heidenspaß daran und hat dann das
hat es dann bestellt für mich habe ich
bezahlt und wer es waren erreicht hat
voll viel freude gemacht
da habe ich schon studiert ich habe 81
angefangen zu studieren also zwischen 81
und 86 müsste das gewoge als leergut
afflecks auf jeden fall als studentin
erstmal 93
und damit immer wieder am ausgangspunkt
oder vielen dank dafür dass du dein auto
zur verfügung gestellt hast du richtig
finde richtig coole mich richtig darauf
gefreut hat spaß gemacht oder jeden fall
ja durch dabei ist also top auto und ich
würde sagen wir kommen zur bewertung und
die beginnen wir mit dem aus die leute
erinnern an der stelle daran dass des
tesla model 3 4 von 10 bekommen hat in
punkto aussehen da muss der golf 6
weniger bekommt das ganz klar für mich
es ist einfach kein schönes auto ich
habe es im video gesagt heute für mich
sieht das manchmal so aus als hätte man
so einen laib brot einfach unten räder
dran geschraubt zwei von zehn ist nicht
das hässlichste auto da draußen aber in
puncto beschleunigung ist die erste
frage eigentlich kommt der golf 6
überhaupt auf 100 km h und ja er kommt
auf 110 6 sekunden ist im vergleich zu
den anderen autos natürlich sehr sehr
wenig aber immer noch besser als einige
autos draußen drei von zehn coolness ja
was soll ich da sagen leute dieser
coolness und golf 6 plus in einem satz
zu verwenden ist schon ein bisschen
paradox ich will jetzt auch nicht zu
heiß sein deswegen wirklich mit müh und
not mit ach und krach zwei von zehn
eigentlich hätte ich lieber eins von
zehn gegeben praktikabilität da kann der
golf punkten man hat unfassbar viel
platz im innenraum dafür dass das auto
an sich nicht riesig ist man hat auch
eine menge stauraum des autors mega
variable man kann die rückbank komplett
umlegen hat eine riesige staufläche ist
ist einfach unfassbar praktisches auto
neun von zehn und gerade was preis
leistung angeht schneidet der golf
extrem gut ab das modell wie es da seht
hat kaum sonderausstattung und liegt
damit kaum über dem listenpreis von
knapp über 20.000 euro dafür bekommt man
ein sehr zuverlässiges sehr ausgereiftes
auto und das ganze ist in dem fall hier
ja noch mal günstiger weil der wagen ja
zwei beziehungsweise drei jahre alt erst
übernommen wurde meiner meinung nach was
preise kaum zu schlagen 10 von 10 und
was wir kommen voran geht ein bisschen
video von mir auch schon gehört wird ich
bin wirklich beeindruckt das ist der
golf ist ein sehr komfortables auto muss
ich sagen auf jeden fall
überdurchschnittlich da würde ich ohne
probleme wenn jetzt ein bisschen mehr
leistung hätte auch langstrecken mit
fast sechs von zehn punkten damit kommt
unser lieber golf auf 32 von 60 punkten
insgesamt liegt damit natürlich am ende
der bisher getesteten fahrzeuge ist aber
auch viel viel viel günstiger als alle
der vergleichs fahrzeuge unterm strich
muss ich sagen für alle die sich keine
riesigen kopf ums thema auto machen
wollen
wirklich gutes fahrzeug ich freue mich
aufs nächste auto am sonntag wird wieder
richtig krass leute drei buchstaben amg
bis dann macht's gut